two all rise for the honorable judge
ethan klein
[Music]
thank you officer everybody please be
seated
today fair people of the jury
we put on trial the creator known as
j station j station is a youtuber who
got popular making 3 a.m horror
challenges his fan base is known as jay
nation he's made up over 6
million subscribers today we put him on
trial for the pot for the following
crimes exploiting tragedies
faking his girlfriend's death for views
offensive and hate crimes hate crimes
geez
this is a first for our youtube court
room
criminal hypocrisy and corrupting the
youth
wow our prosecutor
will be a b you will be prosecuting j
station a b
and a i e and of course will be
defending uh
j station as a rsr resident j
nation member
council a b please proceed with their
opening statements this court is now
in session
please proceed amy thank you your honor
yes you brought up that j station is a
horror channel which i feel is fitting
for his content being that his content
is in fact horrific
some may even say that it has a demonic
presence in how
horrible it is that being said
i hope to enlighten the viewers for
those of you who are not familiar with
jay
and hopefully we can have some kind of
resolution at the end of this
trial okay aien are you a member of the
j nation ain't would you like to say
anything in his defense before we begin
uh well before we begin i have a
question for you is this court
thing is this like is this like a
regular deal
do i have to keep doing this ai
in you are we are role playing and you
are meant to stay in character if you
have quite
meta questions about the court hearing
please save it until after the video
well i was just wondering where i should
be sending my legal fees
this is not order order please stick to
defense
of your client i'm just trying to defend
my wallet
my guy all right okay
station okay this is not my my i'm the
judge
i am not the [ __ ] accountant all
right please
what else are you going to be doing i
mean let's be honest you want to argue
about this now i mean
why are you bringing this up now i just
feel like you know
yeah yeah i i gotta pay i gotta pay for
my motor oil you know
motor oil what does that cost like 20
bucks i mean
give me a [ __ ] brick we treat you
fine all right now is not the time you
want to defend your client
you're trying to ruin another video
order in the court aien
i also need some money to pre-order the
jstation five
pretty good right no
not good he makes good videos they're
funny
next i find it impressive
that a robot can come up with jokes i
mean yeah
this is not about aie in you guys focus
j station we'll have order in this
courtroom
all right that's it that's really all
you guys have okay
moving on let's move on to our first
exhibit
uh our first exhibit of course is crimes
exploiting tragedies a.b would you like
to
introduce um this crime
please let's try on us so we're all
familiar with click bait
but i'm not familiar with any other
creator that has gone
so far to exploit the death
of celebrities other youtubers
and supposedly ex-girlfriends jstation
has done this multiple times
and i will go through each and every
single time
well most of the time she's done i can't
go through all of them but if you please
look at the exhibits you will see what
i'm referring to we have exhibit a
uh the wrapper known as um and excuse me
it's called
x tacion am i right or is it x x x
tachyon
x x x synthesis that's a mouthful we r
people really say x
x x every time they mention they bring
his name up they shorten it to x
yeah x the court will now
will further recognize as x j
uploaded a monetized video entitled xxx
tacion
ouija board challenge at 3am gone wrong
in this video he claims to have made
contact with x through a ouija board
now may i ask you maybe how how recently
after his death was this video posted
this one was uh less than a week less
than one week after
that sure that is quite shameless i will
say now this is a re-upload is that
right because most of these videos have
been removed
correct do we know why the videos were
removed was it in shame or was it in
uh i believe it was in shame and shame
yes
well shame unfortunately
uh is not a crime or is not a
appropriate punishment but let's go
ahead and watch
this video with another 3 a.m challenge
i just got a brand new house guys they
gave me the keys we're going to check it
out right now guys the house is
completely empty
and we brought the ouija board out guys
tonight we're trying to contact
xxx tentacion on the ouija board guys
smash the like button right now guys
let's hit 100k for x
it is so sad he passed away
right now for more ouija board videos
guys we might even try to contact two
plus places
say hello to my new crib
this is lit does that look sick or what
we got freaking marble floors
how many lip videos are going to take
place in this baby get the kitchen yo
we live in large we in charge guys this
is amazing gonna put a sick flat screen
right up there guys i'm probably gonna
spend like 20 000 on furniture guys we
gonna be in a mansion jay nation
[Applause]
no no one can hear us guys
damn brand and there's gonna be a big
ass tv screen
right now guys we're gonna use the ouija
board to contact xxx tentacion we're
gonna put that down by the ouija board
the whole entire time right there i also
got
an instrumental by x hey
hey hey hey
hey all right guys so we just freestyled
to x's b
we got his picture right there if
there's any way to attract a spirit to
the ouija board guys
that's how to do it i mean we just
killed it on the beat guys like
seriously that was lit is anyone moving
the judge asked requests did they crush
it on the beat
um no your honor so that was that was
removed
from the from the video the just because
we didn't want to get copyrighted is
that right
um that's part of it also i cannot find
a re-upload so these are
clips that i had previously put together
um but they pretty much sum up the video
but yeah
i was unfortunately missing the
freestyle
how do we know he didn't crush it
this is this is a good point i guess
it's subjective
aeon you ain't do you believe he crushed
it on the beat
i mean we're using the word subjective
already
come on all right let's proceed thank
you
[Music]
love you sending love sending love
i kept seeing all over twitter people
saying he used to do this he used to do
that but
all that really matters is towards the
end of his life all he really did was
spread out positivity yo what the frick
what the frick
[Music]
demon like so fast wait what the hell
wait whoa whoa what the freak
guys yo
there's something hundred thousand likes
guys we gotta hit a hundred thousand
100k
and we'll open this guys smash the like
button right now for xxx
tentacion we actually communicated with
them do you guys have anything else you
want to ask x
put it down in the comments guys and we
might do a part wow
wow so just to give context for those
who are not aware
when he passed there was a lot of uh
people mourning his loss a lot of people
felt the tragedy of a young
up-and-comer passing too young
and what it appears to me is that j
station
has basically just popped uh capitalized
on that
in order to you know further one of his
videos
i mean he was just trying to get a
hundred thousand prayers
aka a hundred thousand likes right but
maybe he had um good intention
he what he was saying if you get a
hundred thousand likes we'll open the
box
that seems to me as if he would be
benefiting that and not the spirit of
xxx a b do you have anything
oh well sure go ahead abby
yeah we're just going to point out um he
didn't handle the situation
too kindly being that he started the
first half of the video showing off his
house his new mansion
very good point not very sensitive
if this is a video meant to mourn the
passing of this fine young man
showing off his new house uh
is certainly not a way to mourn his
passing
for sure did he ever get the
enough prayers to open the cursed box
i'm not sure on that but he did do a
part two
i wonder what was in it
what the frick a i n what do you think
about
him showing off his house before paying
respects to
to uh x i mean
it's a nice pad i'd show it off to
but don't you think it's disrespectful
to the memory of x to
begin the video by showing off his you
know if you if you
if you paid me a little more i'd buy a
house and show it off too
but unfortunately i'm in this freaking
dump
um what do you think aien what do you
think about the concept of one like
equals one prayer
i mean the logic tracks for me it does
it does yes how
how does someone clicking a like button
equal a prayer how does that track for
you and your infinite knowledge
well i mean it's all about the intention
right i can send you one like equals one
hatred
if i want to but you and but the act of
the act of pressing
with intent to pray sends the prayer
just like when i click like on your
photos that is
me centering hatred hate energy
fair point i mean certainly a fair point
sure
uh the following exhibit do not play
uh x music backwards at 3 am
no pulse reversed wow
couldn't possibly imagine what goes on
in this one i got a mouse now let me use
this
all right now now before we uh move on
to this
what was the reception to his first
video ab
oh he got scrutinized um by the audience
by other creators other people um
on youtube like adam22 who was friends
with x
were very upset they called jay out for
it
and so his decision was to basically
double down and make a part two
yeah so keemstar was actually one of the
people who called out jay
um jay's content's so bad that it's the
one time my life where i sided with
keemstar
and he actually starts this next video
by stating um
what i'm doing is not disrespectful so
for all you keemstar fans watching
all right let's proceed garbage right
[Music]
that xxx tentacion's new song called no
pulse
has some sort of cryptic demonic
messages if you play it in reverse
now guys when you play songs in reverse
it is the creepiest sounding thing you
can ever
imagine so guys i'm going to need 50 000
likes
for this video not prayers this time
before we start this video i just want
to let you guys know right now
uh aien this time he asked for lux not
prayers do you find that disrespectful
he left he asked for what likes not
prayers
i mean a life is powerful too are you
saying it's not
well it seems that that a like would
benefit him and not
uh x i mean i think a like could be very
very powerful in many different ways
would you like to list those ways no
okay
fair enough didn't thank you yes
may i point out that he said 50 000 just
for the record
he's jason oh let me go back to observe
you can ever imagine
so guys i'm going to need 50 000 likes
50
000. right to the problem he
mispronounced it a little bit
okay yeah that
that that that that i just want to let
you guys know right now
that it is definitely not disrespectful
in any kind of way
oh well he just said it there case
closed he said it's definitely
yeah case closed baby yeah
you lose he just in reverse i'm just
letting you guys
why does it look like is his shirt wet
or is it like no i think it's actually
shiny material why is he wearing like a
leather shirt i mean that's just
odd i've never seen anything like that
in my life
what is it made of viola it looks like
it's made of like just
plastic or leather uh
any keemstar fans out there this is not
a disrespectful video
the only reason i know about this
anyways is because i'm a big fan of xxx
what the hell is that what the what the
hell is that
oh my god no way
wait wait are you telling he actually
has a dead animal in this video
i mean it looks like it after he heard
the song
he has a dead rabbit as a prop in his
video
what is wrong with this man why by the
way
he gets massive backlash for the first
one and then proceeds to make a second
one
and use a dead baby rabbit as a prop
why that's so horrific this is terrible
this is very disturbing no pulse reverse
what's the title
voice is coming from my freaking
computer right now smash that like
button right now
let's hit 50. uh dude i'm sorry i just i
like i'm having so much trouble with
this content yeah
how is this real that he has six million
subscribers he's walking around playing
with dead animals talking about
uh xxx tenacion they say it right
no xxs tentacion
what can i do i'm a boomer with a gavel
xxs ten ten tacion
[Music]
talking about talking to a speaker
begging for likes how many times does he
beg for likes in a video
it's like half of the video but yeah
people watch
this millions of people watch this i
find that to be
um yeah frankly grotesque and and
horrific
they probably join in for different uh
reasons
one maybe to check out is fire fits
every time leather
wet leather look yeah 3 000 likes i'll
do a part two listening to more songs
played in reverse
guys i am getting out of here until
daytime with all that being said guys
so why is there a dead rabbit i have no
idea
there's no correlation i mean
he probably killed that rabbit where do
you just find a dead rabbit
i don't know the dark web jay would say
the cursed web demonic
is it is it possible it's alive is it
possible that a rabbit could be
sleeping with its eyes open motionlessly
on his bathroom floor
if it's alive it's a better actor than
jay is
aien how do you justify the the death of
an animal as a prop
i mean what am i supposed to feel
something for
living beings come on
then why do you care about jay station
i mean he gives me some spooks
[Music]
interesting there's a lot of value in
some good spooks i go say they're hard
to come by
do you follow him for the fire fits i
mean i i won't lie that's definitely
contributing factor
this is weird dude i don't like the dead
animal
what i'd like to get to the bottom of
what this rabbit is i'm gonna find it so
odd i mean what is wrong with this one i
don't like it well that's exhibit b
uh exhibit c we continue on following
uh this is a third video no this is
another video called
rest in peace mac miller spirit box
challenge at 3am
speaks about ariana grande wow
this is just one day after mac miller's
tragic death
now as you know ariana grande was his
ex-girlfriend right
and um and uh they were obviously very
close so
to click bait not only his death but her
involvement
is quite low indeed it's almost
beyond belief almost almost almost
demonic
also let the records show that ariana
was going through a lot of bullying at
the time
a lot of roles online were bullying her
for what saying that she should have
been there for him
saying that she should have been there
for him indicating that she had a
part in you know his passing which
obviously is not true but
do you think he do you think he was
trying to tap into that
yes 100
that's insane i can't believe someone
this
uh shameless exists you know i'm not i
wasn't familiar with jstation
like at all i know people have talked
about them a lot
and um i have never really looked for
some reason i just i never really looked
into it
um
this is really a new low i think it's
back with another one as you guys might
have heard by now
mac miller unfortunately passed away
unfortunately by the way
it's almost it's almost insult like i'm
not i'm not familiar with mac miller's
music and stuff but i know
like um x people were very
affected by his death oh yeah and so to
you
to use this footage is so [ __ ] up
it's crazy i mean i again i'm in awe of
of his shamelessness right now
mac miller like he's doing some kind of
memorial for him but he's really
he's contacting his spirit at 3
two days a.m of my favorite things about
mac miller is he
dated ariana that's your favorite thing
bro that he dated a girl
is he also saying her name wrong ariana
what's your i've heard by now
mac miller unfortunately passed away
two days one of my favorite things about
mac miller is he dated
ariana grande ariana i guess it's ariana
i think so right wait but uh i object to
the notion that
that the judge has any authority to come
at someone for mispronouncing
any word in the english language
[Laughter]
uh motion is is accepted yeah he's
recommended
motion granted motion granted certainly
certainly strike from the record
um but don't you find it funny that his
favorite thing about
her him is that he dated her like that
he's a fan and he's like yeah
yeah that's my favorite thing not his
music or anything else about his life
this girl is like my dream girl i would
do anything to just date this girl
and mac miller actually did it guys big
shout out to him for that
dude what is wrong with you what is this
big shout out
shout out mac you actually did it rest
in peace homie wow
what the frick what the freak
how what how is this guy real i mean i i
oh boy this is tough man i mean ariana
grande
for mac miller's passing and guys i
really don't think it's ariana's fault
at all
you said it's all positive energy
positivity positive
positivity mac we love you oh my god
can i say that his tattoo looks like it
looks like there's a seagull making a
diarrhea
yeah if the signal is just over like an
inch it just looks like bird poop
uh that's it that's all that's all i
have to say about that
guys he's okay
what is this a siriana grande bro you're
just talking about ariana grande
and how a lot of people are saying this
is her fault
wow wow wow wow wow
wow that is so [ __ ] up dude you're
playing with people's lives these are
real people and she
this is beyond insanity
i i can't believe this what the [ __ ]
what the frick is this is so let me ask
you this
i wonder if this is if youtube would
take this down today or is this
acceptable content
i mean what does it say about the people
that watch this unironically i'm just so
confused
um i feel like they probably never
imagined they would even be
confronted with content like this like
we don't have rules this crazy
it's like how do you even define yeah
this is sick uh community guideline
uh 6a no desecrating the death of
no calling in the dead at 3am in the
morning challenge please yeah
i guess they could well they do have a
carve out for like shocking content so
maybe this would ponder that
maybe to add on to what you said judge
about how
you're surprised that you know you
haven't heard more about him
for so long he flew under the radar i
feel like that's what makes him very
unique is like because
his audience is was so young or is still
so young that a lot of people didn't
catch on to until it was like too late
oh my god
yeah maybe he is trying to tell us
something mac are you showing her
for some sort of reason does she have
anything to do with this
i don't know that was insane that was
definitely mac miller why would you even
insinuate
yeah i mean that's does she have
anything to do with this
i don't think anyone is excusing her of
killing him
dude no well some people were accusing
her not of killing her him but of like
not being there but he says does she
have anything to do with this
like she well regardless wow all i have
to say is
this guy is a [ __ ] shitty human being
this guy needs to be tried in real court
i love that he said that she's his dream
girl and he would do anything to date
her
and then goes on to make the worst
content that she probably hates
yeah because it's just feeling the drama
against her i love her did you have
anything to do with this
man this guy is kind of the worst dude
ever it's kind of
something else man um
exhibit how
and the how was the reception to this
one what was this
this was before x right amy no this one
was after x
oh so he's really enjoying the the
negative attention you have to assume
yeah i mean yeah and these views these
videos were
were widely viewed yeah um this video
um got 34k likes when it first came out
in 82k dislikes
right but the views were probably high
yeah the views the views were high i'm
sorry i don't know the number on top of
my head
it was a million yeah on the count of
exploiting tragedies uh aien
would you like to mount a defense for
the defendant j station please go ahead
uh well i guess i have a question for
you
what are your thoughts on uh what are
your thoughts on life after death
i will entertain it although i do not
know where this is going
i believe that uh there is no life after
death
do you entertain the possibility that
that may be something that occurs
i can entertain the possibility there is
a window
in your brain where there could be life
after death okay very
interesting interesting and in that
window is where j
station and i live he
in that window may actually
be talking beyond the grave
there is no way to disprove
now aien what are the chances that
someone like mac miller
or x x x ten tacion
would be communing with a
j station of all people on earth
the chances are about as much as you
just said you entertained
very small but there is a chance
and so it is a chance
if he is communing with the dead
for real how does that make this
still acceptable to pull their ghost
from the grave to disturb their inter
eternal rest
for views on youtube to clickbait their
death
how is this even um even even to
um entertain your notion i still fail to
see how that justifies his content
well i mean i'm sure he generated a lot
of likes during these videos and that's
a lot of prayers
that's useful so your your ultimate
point is that
he's he's generating prayers which how
do prayers help
uh the dead by the way how do we prove
that that's useful to them
and not just a j station
well that's a whole other core we're
going to have to go to a whole other
court for that one
oh okay okay fair enough well
i find that uh somewhat interesting uh
argument thank you ai n a b
would you like to rebut or prosecute
please
proceed uh yes so the defense attorney
is trying to cause a reasonable doubt in
the case but the point being made isn't
that he is or isn't actually contacting
the dead as you pointed out you're on
your honor the problem is that he's
exploiting
their death so whether it's true or not
it's the promise
and the exploiting of the deceased aien
let me ask you this why is it that he
only contacts recently desist
deceased celebrities knowing it would
generate the most
buzz if he truly wanted to commune with
the dead
he would certainly have an interest in
other people who have passed on
who are not in the news
well i mean i i'm not an expert on no
jstation but i'd have to imagine that
the
farther back you go for someone's demise
the worst it's like
it's like driving through a tunnel the
signal is worse it's hard to
to reach their spirit has drifted
further and therefore they're
more difficult to reach fascinating i
don't know if the long island would
agree with that long island medium
disagrees with you
and i'll have that long island medium
but but fair enough i think that's an
interesting analogy
okay ila what do you think
i listened to both of these uh
fellas fellas and uh distinguished
gentleman
yes a b to make more sense in this
point and i side with him so i think
i mean i mean aien obviously makes
his best attempt at a fair defense here
you know
saying well maybe he is communing with
the dead
but um ultimately
as ultimately i feel that that point is
moot i believe that j station
is capitalizing
on the newsworthiness shamelessly to
invoke the name of ariana grande and to
insinuate
to ask did you have something to do with
this
is shameless it's irresponsible
and it's uh it's it's frankly uh
disgraceful and unbelievable
i couldn't believe what i was saying and
i think even worse than that it's just
not cool
if you're not cool if she's your dream
girl that's some respect for your dream
girl good luck in the afterlife with her
idiot
um wow
j station you are guilty on all counts
of exploiting tragedy
and may the court add that this is
possibly one of the worst
most egregious examples i've seen of
irresponsible trashy content on youtube
and for that
i sentence you j station to 20 billion
years
of demonetization 10 gazillion dislikes
and jstation they have something for the
end no
it all adds up it's not good
well you know how sometimes they give
like mass murderers like i sented you to
a thousand years yeah it's like we get
it
that's what's happening here and
furthermore j station
i sentence you to be
ouija boarded when you pass away by uh
your by your most hated
um by your go and i and i wish that your
ghosts curse you in the afterlife
and that your ouija board and that your
girl ex-girlfriend ouija boards you
no good what the freak
no good in the afterlife i don't i guess
i don't hold any
jurisdiction there guilty guilty guilty
wow i'm offended this court is offended
shame on you
wow next
on to the next criminal charge for
offensive
hate crimes um
this sounds quite serious jay station's
offensive
gay videos he made a video called we
kissed ordering
gay potion from the dark web at 3am
one must wonder why does everything on
his channel have to happen at 3 a.m
guys back with another banger video we
went back on to the dark web and we
actually discovered there's a gay
posting guy
some potion that if you drink will turn
anywhere
let me may i ask you a question if you
didn't want to [ __ ] your homie why would
you even order a gay potion to begin
with
you know what i mean that's a great
observation
they really get into character uh their
roles in this
i think you're just gay dude i mean you
don't need a potion man
so who is gay good question who is gay
day for exactly one hour guys this is
crazy okay i'm a straight guy
are you straight i'm a straight guy i'm
not gay bro okay
guys check out j hills
what was that what was that by the
preacher you ugly right
man this is so weird how do you even
think of this what
yeah how do you even think of this [ __ ]
do we does he get points for creativity
because it's
so odd also i
this one is even weirder to happen at 3
a.m
yeah it's almost like they actually just
want to [ __ ]
just he he just here's the thing he's
like this guy that needs to um
monetize everything in his life so he's
like i'm gonna [ __ ] my homie let's
monetize this [ __ ] first
gay potion from the dark web for one
hour for us guys this
is going to be a banger chain a suit
yeah it smells
fruity bro fruity yeah man it smells
like a fruit let me smell it
why would you drink this if you weren't
gay why would you drink this
knowing that you're going to want to
[ __ ] your homies they're just doing it
for research
this is an educational channel now right
what is the
ugandan preacher think why are you gay
yeah
right this am i gonna just start making
out with you
you don't come near me bro guys okay
okay
we're going to do the rock paper
scissors rock paper scissors shoot
oh i'm whipped cricket gargle
so we know it's there gargle like my
jizz
how long did it take like this last only
one hour this last only one hour i don't
know how long it takes but he started
feeling his tip
for you bro how's it feel like i feel
like a little bit like a little
weird vibe you know yeah oh my god
did we have stupidity on the charges
criminal stupidity no that's not here
um i will ask you to add that we will
move
to add that to the charges
well it's clearly super offensive i mean
yeah what if you get stuck
like this first of all imagine what a
nightmare yeah
well first of all the insinuation that
being gay has some kind of
characteristics or qualities yeah and
then the other
notion being that it's some kind of
curse that you have to buy on the dark
web
but it's like oh i'm gay now i have
different affects and i act this way
yeah it's like they're just normal
people
um just suck your homies dick bro i know
what this is about
doesn't that make you
[Music]
[Laughter]
yet dog yo jay station
[Laughter]
wow i think he's feeling some type of
way
preacher ugandan preacher
you are gay yeah and he didn't even
drink the potion yet
you are a transgender oh my god he's not
transgender as far as i'm aware
so who is gay so far ahead yeah
so far him because he drank the potion
but j station's already groping him so
bro why is he talking differently this
is super offensive
dude is he talking so crazy and he's
swirling his hair
oh okay like you don't like to kiss like
i don't like to talk to you then
oh my god this is i can't believe what
i'm watching this is super [ __ ]
this is super [ __ ]
this is so odd wow this is i feel like
this is something you would see in like
the 1950s
right and like a cartoon with blackface
and [ __ ] i was just gonna say that that
feels like something that would be okay
when like blackface was okay
this is blackface vibes for sure on
youtube for kids
why the [ __ ] does he have a sarcophagus
in his
i don't know this was bubba john's house
yeah
you know his whole house is empty
there's like no furniture except he just
has a sarcophagus
is that where he sleeps at night
possibly possibly i could see him
sleeping that turns me on
i have that same sarcophagus just for
the record
why what's wrong why wait why well
oddly enough this is going off track but
my parents got a divorce that's the only
thing my dad wanted from the divorce
it's a cd holder i don't know and it
ended up being
a d holder wait how is it a cd holder
you said you have the same one how is it
one yeah how is it a cd holder where is
the city oh and the inside is just like
a big like
line of to hold cds stacks on top of
each other yeah
wait so it opens hold on hold on your
parents got divorced and all he wanted
was the sarcophagus
it's so bizarre i know that's all that's
all i wanted and then he gave that to
you
no he he uh well me him my
my dad and my brother lived together for
a while and then he ended up getting his
own place and he left it with us so
kept in the family so you got foisted
yeah it sounds like he likes it
trump tell us the truth do you like it
the sarcophagus yeah um it made a great
pop
prop for my jstation video i'll tell you
that
fair enough all right let's proceed
troubling information
get a bunch of makeup i'm down you want
to go shopping
wait did jay wait hold on did jay drink
the potion at this point or no
no he has he has a separate video that's
the next exhibit so why is he
why what is so what is he doing he's
just and he's just playing along
makes you want to make him a sandwich
apparently
which is also like all feminine
qualities is making sandwiches
or being gay is feminine and feminine
yeah yeah yeah you would be in the
kitchen
yeah fascinating
hey danny so coming in a little oh man
oh my god your nails aren't even done
no we should get them done i'd like you
better like this probably better like
that
ah thank you oh my god
do i need to finish this i mean this is
insane no you you don't you can go on to
the next one okay
i mean i do this oh wait and then he
comes out of it
yeah he comes oh i want to watch him
come out of it
yeah then he tries to rape him oh well
yeah i gotta finish this
it's almost over
[Music]
your tattoos oh my god with pink nose it
looks so
sexy you look like the
[Music]
okay first of all there's a couple of
priests uh
suppositions i have to address one that
any gay man would want to [ __ ] jake
station
you're saying that is impossible just
because he's gay doesn't mean he wants
to [ __ ] this guy i mean
let's be honest right not much going on
there
what about those fire fits did you see
the montclair beanie bits
he spends a lot of money on his clothes
at least his hats
um and then the other one is that gay
people are rapists apparently too right
he's like i'm gay now i just need to
rape you
be scared of gays
like what the [ __ ] is
[Applause]
get this of me what the [ __ ] am i doing
bro you're trying to kiss me you're
trying to make out why are you laughing
oh this is this is
this is something man i mean really
oh boy that's hard to watch okay could
have been a history piece if it was made
50 years ago
yeah maybe in 50 years before we
move forward can i just draw some notes
for the court
wait oh your video is frozen hold up
oh my god on such a goofy frame too
from the top okay um so i just want to
draw to the attention of the court
a few observations uh first of all i
believe jay and his friend have never
met a gay person in their life but
also they believe that i think they
believe that if you're gay you believe
that you're a girl
i just want to point that out especially
for the next video that's coming out
you sort of yeah i should draw attention
to that okay moving on
uh j station drinks the gay potion
coming out of the closet
is the title of this one let's proceed
herman
[Music]
god's name was that why was kermit in
the movie
he's a normal character in jay's videos
he drinks the gay potion in another
video
oh even kermit gets in on it
you're feeling fruity it sort of feels
whoa
no i sort of feel
i drank that potion don't come near me
bro don't go i think it's starting to
kick in though
i think it is did you feel like this
yeah bro do not come
are they just playing out their gay
fantasies yeah yeah totally
totally on camera also we already saw
what
like if this was an experiment whatever
the other guy
we already saw what it does to him and
then
jay decides even though he knows what's
going to happen
to do it he has to do it the real
question is
why haven't you guys done it together
or have they well that begs the question
certainly doesn't it
well i get the idea so he's acting like
a female he's putting on makeup
like a stupid female can i say a bimbo
he's got a shirt tied up he's putting on
makeup
does he attempt to rape his buddy or
anything
yes he does of course he does i love
that
does he attempt to rape his buddy yes
your honor
yeah yeah where's money okay okay okay
should i be like like this yeah yeah
pull this pole is nice yeah yeah
bro you are so you are enjoying this so
much all right all right
so here comes the rape i'm sure i like
that
say sexy
i know deep down you want it no i don't
want that
[Music]
i got you in the corner now i got you in
the corner
no just take a sip of potion bro it'll
be fun
bruh don't kiss me girl don't kiss me
bro what what's wrong with my face
did you do this to me oh my god oh my
god
well of course any any any i won't speak
for the whole gay community but i
i find this just yeah super offensive
super super offensive
also gay people don't necessarily wear
makeup i mean
what what the [ __ ] does that about
okay kermit the frog gay i get it
i don't know that i need to watch kermit
the frog go gay
black santa this sounds interesting am i
am i okay to skip kermit the frog ab
yes okay so
on to more offensive hate crimes jay has
a video called black santa
video is actually entitled do not call
black santa on facetime
at 3am calling santa claus on facetime
actually works who is black santa
a.b um he is a fictional character
that uh jay has made up i believe um
that he's trying to pass off as a real
character who
visits um black children so there's a
white sand and a black santa and uh
the j mcu i don't know how you want to
call it
j universe that's insane that is
so [ __ ] up is there a game
segregating christmas i think even in
the 1950s they didn't
have a black santa you know what i mean
like santa was still white then
i guess maybe it's good black santa but
i don't know it seems a little [ __ ]
especially from jay
let's take a look at black santa shall
we hmm
but i was at the mall yesterday and i
actually saw
a black santa guys i didn't even know
black santa existed
why didn't i know that roxanna existed
guys i thought santa was
white but no i guess there's two santa
claus guys tonight we're actually going
to facetime
blacks 3 a.m let me know guys what you
want for christmas so the insinuation
being that black santa's creepy somehow
that's why we need to call him at 3am
is that what you say he said i have to
call black santa at 3am why at 3am
because 3am is the spooky hour
all of his creepy videos are at 3am
believe it or not that's putting it
lightly compared to what he actually
thinks
section i'm sure santa claus is actually
going to watch this video
regular santa has a santa claus hotline
so i'm sure if we look through google
hard enough we're actually going to find
black santa's phone number and why do
you think there's a black santa like
maybe black santa goes
how does he talk these moms clothes into
this kids or what that could possibly
make sense like that's the only thing
is there like a chinese santa for the
asian people or i don't even know well i
think the black santa does go to the
black people and like
like like he said bro the white one goes
to the white i mean guys how crazy would
it be if santa actually brings a black
elf here
oh my god guys
so wait does that mean that white sand
is like i ain't delivering packages
there's no black kids
right and black santa's like [ __ ] white
kids i'm only delivered back
like they beef they have turf wars
anyway here's a picture of black santa
he's got his contact number and his
number guys i mean now guys we're gonna
actually message him just because we
don't
yeah how do you get his number dude that
looks [ __ ] he's actually realer
he could be busy right he's santa yeah
he's probably caring for just us right
that's right
well hold on why would black santa talk
to a bunch of white kids
plot hole
it's 3am he doesn't see he'll refer us
to the white santa line okay
right now guys i'm going to say black hi
uh hi we're looking for
white hi black santa do you have a white
santa's phone number
there what the hell he knows my name
i don't know oh my god what the hell
guys
yeah he must know everything guys i'm
thinking this is a real santa he knows
my name guys
this acting is so [ __ ] horrendous
what the frick oh my god you guys he's a
real santa he knows
everything uh
to watch this unironically you really
would have to be like i don't know
five that's what i was wondering too i
feel
like even 10 year olds would say this is
stupid
yeah i think five that's
almost getting close to theodore's age
but then at that point when your
audience is five years old and you're
talking about like gay stereotypes and
black santa
you should be in jail not not that jail
real jail
you know the song he knows when you are
sleeping he knows when you're awake
10 a.m guys it's 3 10. oh my god the
hell oh that dude
i gotta skip forward it's too long i'm
freaking scared oh my god is there here
should i
specifically focus on black santa
demands fried chicken
well that sounds [ __ ] up
what oh my god
oh my god
do you ever think black santa gets
offended by being referred to as black
santa
you ever think he's like my my name is
craig or something
well i've seen it all folks
i literally just saw
i can't believe what i just saw
can i i gotta watch that again i mean
we're just saying it's for
five-year-olds
i wouldn't even do this for the regular
santa i'm scared
[Music]
it's like a jump scare
[Music]
so black santa is rude he's abrasive
he's creepy
he sounds like a criminal he's like ho
ho ho [ __ ] where's my fried
chicken
not good is that an actual black person
or is it black face i think it was a
black dude
okay from from what i could tell yeah
what am i to make of this i mean really
let's let's really take this
in here um this has to be comedy right
should we check in with ain
ai in what am i i need help def i need
help contextualizing this please
uh you don't have to check in with me
right now you don't want to touch this
one
even aien you don't you know you don't
want to touch this one
defense rests interesting
but but is this comedy i mean what is
happening here
i mean what is this i mean what really
is i'm blown away
well there's more let's let's keep
watching uh he continues to be
aggressive and curse
oh my god it's black santa
what what
bra station so santa's like a
ex-con i mean or like santa's like
who is this black santa i mean in their
mind
he's like a i mean
i'm speechless yeah help me out here ian
help me
this is your clients
it seems his battery's low you better
charge that for the closing statement
[Music]
santa please okay we got lots of cookies
chicken yeah
yo santa we tried to order chicken we
tried to order it we don't
it's close it's closed something that we
can do
now we got lots of cookies and merry
christmas
so insane this was on youtube i mean
this is
[Music]
[Music]
guys
oh i'm sorry santa oh my god oh yeah we
walked in there with smokey upstairs
what was he doing
in the room oh my god dude i think he
was smoking in there
yeah it was that wow dude i i i i i
i this could also live in the 1950s
probably now
j station bring live from 1950
when they were like trying to uh portray
black people as criminals
yeah right after slavery this would fit
right in
a i n
uh you're gonna have to repeat the
question
what about a b a-i-a-i-e-n why are they
not guilty of a hate crime
well i mean what do you mean i'm not the
judge are they guilty i can't tell you
you're supposed to make a person you're
supposed to persuade me and their
defense you understand how this works
i mean i i i don't know i don't know
sometimes the best defense is to plead
fair enough he's pleading the fifth
well this is [ __ ] i mean this is just
this is just um it's unbelievable
how long was this content on youtube did
youtube do anything about it did it get
a lot of views can you give me some
background on this ab
okay so this video was still up
um all the way up to the last of my
knowledge was
um beginning of 2020 and youtube didn't
remove it i believe he removed it after
some reach a recent controversy but no i
believe you removed it
the views were in the millions oh my god
reception
reception um so in the final exhibit i
included some comments
from this video and you'll see the
impact that his videos have on small
children
aien do you on the charge of
hate crimes and racial
stereotypes just hate in general
what do you say in defense of gay
station
which he dubbed himself of course
do not get paid enough to defend this
i'm out
okay aien does not get paid
enough to defend this i think that's an
admission of guilt i think if i can read
between the lines aien is saying
this dude is a racist yeah he's guilty
i think and that's coming from aien
who's not even a human being he has no
reputation to
even defend to uphold
a b do you have a retort to your
do you have a retort i can't imagine
what it would be but please go ahead
uh no i believe that's what the kids
refer to as a w
you know be interesting if you defended
j station now because i'm not really
sure
oh that it would be interesting i mean
the only defense i would have is that
he's
possibly [ __ ] in the head doesn't know
better oh yeah
so oh see there you go uh mental illness
you can claim that in court mental
illness
but we don't have enough information to
go off that so ela
uh on the charges of of hate crimes and
terrible crimes against humanity uh we
find the defendant
obviously and gravely
horrifically it unforgivably
irredeemably
guilty as charged
that's horrible stuff i mean i'm i'm
frankly shocked that that
about i'm shocked that it was conceived
i'm shocked that
it was executed that it was uploaded i'm
shocked that people watch it
i'm shocked that it was is successful
content on youtube the whole thing is
just uh
incredible and it leads perfectly into
our next crime
which is corrupting the youth we have
gone through the trouble of looking
through the comment section on just one
of the videos the black
santa one because i believe it's
important to prove to the ladies and
gentlemen of the jury
that his fans are indeed young and
impressionable
very young and impressionable so we went
through the comment section
and here are a few of the choice
comments i'll be doing a lot of pausing
here so bear with me on this one
i feel this this one actually just is
very sad
i feel very sad because you said brown
people are evil and i'm brown well i
agree with you young man that is pretty
sad
can the other santa what the freak
call the other santa and tell them what
happened please so this is
i mean like the otto santa would be
white santa come save the day yeah
but the kid is like super convinced by
this whole thing
look at the way black santa act and jay
station like
favorited this comment which i think
is odd is oddly telling i don't care if
this offends
any [ __ ] this is hilarious
from todd todd age five
i wish you could see people's age online
i feel like that would solve like
all the problems of the internet
instantly that's true
like when you're getting harassed by
someone on twitter and they're getting
under your skin
if torah was like jeff age seven you'd
be like oh my god i'm getting annoyed by
a seven-year-old
nobody would ever take that person
seriously and rightfully so
this is the reason i don't like black
people damn dog really
again even edited huh interesting from
the
ultimate gamer ultimate gamer cg
age six
you would think that if you even saw one
comment like this on your video you'd
think you know what
i gotta read i steered wrong
yeah exactly this video may not be right
why did evil santa gotta be black good
question dexter
good question
you should buy fried chicken then call
black santa so why would they even have
21 up votes
that's like the whole premise of the
video do you understand
like the age and mentality of these
people
maybe they think he'll act different
based on the premise she provided
they're giving him advice get the
chicken before he comes next time you
can have a good interaction with them
people say this video is races by the
way
how old do you have to be to call to
spell it races
i don't think it's races or
maybe not from america but
but everything else is pretty good i
mean races i don't know
black santa is so evil then white santa
dominion age three and a half
grade kinder just call the white santa
again really sensible advice from a
child
and there you have it um there's also
some comments that are worth going over
because i find these interesting
there's another video where he makes a
voodoo doll of his ex-girlfriend
um his ex-girlfriend accused him of
abusing
him and so his response to these very
serious allegations
was to make a voodoo doll of her and
punish her
makes sense but these are real
allegations she laid against him
and this was his response 1.8 million
views anyway the comments here were also
interesting let's take a look
did ako died bruh eco gonna get it like
a [ __ ] boy she
need this brutal
so what can you give some context to
this is the girl yeah
yeah aiko i call yeah
because she yeah
i wish you could get her in your house
so we could watch her
suffer jesus but anyway we have
imaginations oh my god
so sadistic
papa likes that she nerves to get hurt
by voodoo doll
okay thank you jared h uh
eight jay you are savage a cool savage
four upvotes oh yeah she deserves that
i'm a murder eco i ko i'm a murder ico
billy h3
imma come up to her block and shotgun
her
fascinating well there you have it i
think i mean this is just a small sample
just to show
who we're dealing with here and the kind
of content he's influencing so
on the count of corrupting the youth
it's quite clear
that there's no deliberation needed ai
ian do you have anything to say in his
defense i mean i'll just throw it to you
real quick i mean my defense would
probably be that uh
holding someone accountable for their
comment section is a dicey road i mean
i've seen some fried brains when i've
scrolled down on the h3 podcast i'll
tell you that much
fair fair enough certainly not a bad uh
defense and a b
any retort um just that the
comments are in relation to the actual
content
they are showing their in response to
what jay is trying to betray
oh well let's look let's let's not mint
let's
let's look the dude's [ __ ] he's
guilty right
come on but in in summary
you know in closing
on the j station as a whole
[Music]
aien do you have anything to say in his
defense
is he redeemable in any way he is
accused mind you of exploiting
tragedies hate crimes
and corrupting the youth what say you
it's uh i mean it's not looking great
[Laughter]
wow anything else
but maybe he can maybe he can pull a
u-turn i'm not sure
on his content you never know so you're
so basically what you're saying is
he is guilty of everything but maybe he
can redeem himself
somehow that's a possibility
sounds like okay well the possibility of
content parole
baby content for all
okay well his defense has said he's
guilty ab yeah i'm not really sure where
to go from this but please go ahead
um i think this is the one time in my
life where i'm going to say this
but in closing i think keemstar was
right about this guy
he's a problem that's all
strike from the record you are in
contempt of court a b um
first of all you're responsible for this
first of all a b
it's not like keemstar has any unique
insight
literally anyone who hasn't been
lobotomized can look at this content and
know that it's [ __ ] up
so why why bring keemstar into it as
some
authority
i don't know i just order conte hold
hey i hold a b in contempt of court
mother [ __ ] hey i have one final thing
i would like to put forward
go ahead i noticed that we haven't seen
a yet one final piece of evidence where
is sonic exe
do you want to watch you have new
evidence to submit to the court
i would like to submit
okay sonic exe
[Laughter]
and and you believe that this video will
redeem
him in some in some way is that as uh um
to understand
i'm just trying to say that this very
well might be the uno
reversal card of this whole trial
okay can i get a link to uh please
approach the stand and submit
uh sonic exe please i don't think aien
can stand oh you don't have legs can you
put it i'll do it yeah a b will do it
okay i have legs no need to instantly
prove it stand up just never prove it
stand up liar i just i just don't
want to see them you don't want to see
these i'm a little embarrassed
okay they look like an inverted ostrich
claw
man i love this video very embarrassing
okay so we have with us the final
surprise segment that could be a uno
reversal card
last minute introduced by the defense
uh let's see here sonic exe
is apparently he mixes his dna in an egg
to create sonic the hedgehog all right
we are actually trying to create
sonic.exe guys
last year this time what is sonic.exe
i i think it's best to have dan describe
it and dan's really a big fan of this
video
then you would like to call dan to the
witnesses dan dan are you speaking for
defense or prosecution
i i i can be an impartial um
you're an expert witness yeah an expert
for which side i guess ian
well ian is the one that dan is my
witness
dan you are expert witness for defensive
justice
i am a fairly big fan of sonic exe
jstation okay so dan as the uh expert
tell me what is sonic exceed uh as far
as i can tell i think it's like a
a creepypasta kind of thing that's
floated around the internet for a while
about a cursed video game
some sort of uh you know long
buried sonic spin-off um
and if you play it it's kind of like
first thing i'm good sorry it's kind of
like the ring
you know if you watch the video in the
ring you die like a few days later
if you play this cursed sonic game
you'll
your head will explode or some [ __ ] so
um
jstation doesn't seem to really
understand that
or what exe
means or really anything because he
seems to think that
sonic is like a it's a creature
i guess do you think he doesn't know who
sonic the hedgehog is
well he probably knows what sonic the
hedgehog is but
i don't think he really understood the
urban legend when he
created this video because it it takes a
very weird
turn very quickly involving some eggs
and
insemination and dna well the court
would like to note that this video has
3.5 million views and an overwhelming
like ratio
oh yeah yeah this is a banger so in this
scene where i'm about to watch he
inserts his dna into an egg
what what dna is actually to take off
the blood
i already have my dna inside of this
we're gonna just
inject it into the egg so
i'm just gonna wiggle it around guys
these eggshells are actually
pretty freaking hard but it should go in
it finally went
inside guys these eggs are a lot
stronger than the white eggs so i'm just
looking
do we really want do we really want kids
taking blood out of their veins and
trying to take their blood and inject
any eggs the dna
in my objective
yes this is not an encouraging tale this
is a
cautionary tale he is warning children
to not put their dna into an egg and
insert
sonic exe ever ever
okay by doing it
he's trying to show you the consequences
okay fair enough thank you
he's taking one he's taking one for the
rest of us
is we need to bandage this thing up
there can't be any hole
inside of the egg this will seal the
hole completely shut
we're just going to tape this over the
egg right here and we have
the egg okay let's get forward
i have a time stamp here where he
comes home later and discovers the egg
has cracked open and given birth no way
what the freak is the problem look
where what the frick what's the prick
oh my gosh what the freak is wrong with
it it's not just like a toy you put in
water
that's just like a toy you put in water
and it grows or is it something else
it's sonic exe dude what are you talking
about
something look at that does that look
like sonic guys
it's like blue it looks like a blue
skeleton or something like that dude and
it's like a mouse or a hedgehog or
something so honestly guys i have to say
this is obviously he's just making kids
content that is like super absurd
the problem is when you mix in all this
racial stereotypes and
like vendettas against his exes and [ __ ]
like that because if they're willing to
believe a premise is absurd as this
then they're going to believe that black
santa is real and he just wants fried
chicken and all this nonsense
um this is not helping j station
you can play longer maybe i should turn
into something it was working guys like
that is definitely looking like it's a
hedgehog or an animal okay so let's skip
forward
to when the bl the sonic has grown up
a bit and um here it is dangerous i
think this is
actually sonic exe all right guys i'm
gonna open it up right now
whoa whoa what is that what is what is
that moving in there
what is that i don't know i don't know i
don't know i'm gonna open it
i'm gonna open it
it's a mouse that they've shitty spray
painted blue
look at this thing that's freaking sonic
it's like a blue freaking hedgehog or
something guys
it's obviously a mouse or mouse is so
cute it's not a hedgehog
certainly not a hedgehog it's not a
hedgehog
definitely not it okay uh the hamster
ends up biting jay
and now he becomes possessed let's see
what happens here
wow it is blue it's a blue freaking
sonic
[Music]
oh jeez
are you okay bro
you're hitting me
he kind of body slammed that poor mouse
didn't he
man better to take out sonic xu before
he strikes again
he can add it to his other collection of
dead animals with this rabbit
[Music]
so he's become sonic
that's awesome oh my god guys i just saw
him run up the stairs
oh my god what is this thing that sonic
exc
fit in guys the legit vietnamese who's
this goon
that's big ahmed wait why does he look
familiar
did we talk about him i think we've seen
this video before oh
sonic bit me this video is [ __ ] dumb
how is this defending him what is the
purpose of this what am i missing here
go ahead go ahead this was your idea
i i really don't know how you can watch
this and decide this is not
like top-tier content and so
what is your point here how does this
how does this absolve
j station so once again referred to my
my star witness here this he would agree
with me
is this one of the greatest videos ever
made this video's fire i mean i
i don't know what to tell you judge
ethan with all with respect with respect
and why is this one of the greatest
videos ever made can you unpack that for
me please
dude he got super powers from a freaking
from a freaking hedgehog sonic exe dude
hmm interesting point it's got twists
it's got turns it's got excitement
i'm gonna go check up on him oh my god
guys this is just got bit by it
sonic got exe
yeah i have to admit they actually did a
really good job
that's kind of impressive yeah
i think if aien has
effectively um distracted
this court yeah but let us refocus
and well listen guys here we are it's
it's i mean
look on on the offense of exploiting
tragedies we find him guilty guilty
guilty guilty
absolutely and horrendously unforgivably
unredeemably
guilty j station
you are one of the most ill-conceived
irredeemable unbelievable channels i've
ever
had the displeasure of seeing on youtube
i mean what's what's more surprising
than the content itself is the amount of
success he's found
in it i
sentence uj station
did you hear that it was like super loud
noise upstairs
maybe as a demon from a ouija board i
sent it to you j
station to a billion years of watching
your
own content guilty guilty guilty
i sent once you break and in the
afterlife i sense you to
move the hands of a trillion ouija
boards
hands you know how they put their hands
on the ouija board and then it will
spell out
what the frick what the work so when
kids go do a ouija board
when he dies it'll say what the frick
and they'd be like j station what the
[ __ ]
guilty guilty kelty
sonic.exe guys thanks for watching
thank you judge klein um
yes the judge needs to say court is
adjourned
i think the judge is adjourned
judge is already disruptive the judge is
gone judge is out of here okay
uh
all right